I'm going to start right away with this
article from the new Republic that we
did Cover but this is important context
when I scroll down I want to see if they
if they kept their horrifying and
ridiculous statement on right-wing rage
read this it says it would be
understandable for Starbucks to suddenly
grow wary of overt Pride displays
considering how bad right-wing rage has
become Target stores in five different
states received bomb threats over the
weekend and had to be evacuated Liars
but there had been no such Fury directed
at Starbucks now hold on there a minute
the new Republic is outright lying yep
the bomb threats came from left Wingers
who were upset that Target pulled their
uh their pride merchandise we have this
story from I believe we have the daily
wire First Multiple Target stores across
U.S hit with bomb threats for quote
betraying the lgbtq plus Community
according to a report and if you don't
trust the daily wire let me bring up the
Washington Post who reports the exact
same thing news outlets in Vermont New
Hampshire New York received the same
threatening email Saturday according to
South Burlington police chief Sean uh
police chief Sean Burke the message
which accused Target of betraying the
lgbtq community named a store in South
Burlington Vermont and once in
Plattsburgh New York and in a Keene and
West Lebanon New Hampshire
for the new Republic to call that
right-wing rage this is what the left
does they're lying to you well they
didn't technically lie because it's a
different sentence they say the first
sentence is considering how uh how the
the right wing rage had become end of
thought new thought Target stores in a
different location receive bomb threats
and yeah
they have to do a different paragraph
they're literally technically you have
to do a different paragraph if you
actually want to say this is an
unrelated different thought so so
it's not referencing the rage in the
second season it is Ian uh I I encourage
you to go back to fifth grade grammar
and study uh oh I'm a grammar Nazi my
man so let's talk about paragraph
structure and what the intent of a
paragraph is and why a paragraph
contains multiple sentences right if
your first sentence lays out the premise
the second sentence is a part of the
premise of the first sentence of your
paragraphs adding on to whys they might
be where so they are quite literally
calling the bomb threats right-wing rage
no they're not literally doing that
let's be real what is the intent there
the intent they're going to be
manipulated and think it is right so
that's their intent so if that is their
intent then they're lying so if it's not
reply though it's a different kind of
manipulation than lying it it is alive
false insinuation I'm not sure yes it's
all semantic it's so this sentence
Target stores in five different states
we're seeing bomb threats over the
weekend and had to be evacuated that
sentence isolated and of itself is a is
a fact statement if you add a sentence
before it which is an opinion changing
the context of the later information
your intention is to prevent is to
present misinformation to individuals
your intention is to present
false information to a person so they
believe false things
that's just as simple as it can be put
they are lying and so this is what
really happened what really happened is
this has been some this has been ongoing
and the the the attacks are either are
rather sophisticated at first when we
got the news so I I think I was in we're
hanging out as Memorial Day weekend
we're hanging out in Charleston West
Virginia I get a text asking me if this
is true CBS posted an email that was to
us we had never received that email we
checked never received it so how did
someone else get an email that said two
members at timcast we have no idea but
we did see we did get something not the
same but similar and so we forward it to
our security company I believe they're
having law enforcement take care of it I
don't know you know what else is going
on beyond that but at first I said this
seems like a hoax like someone's trying
to smear the left like a false flag to
make him seem violent or whatever
upon further investigation and further
reading my conclusion was likely that's
a bit too out it's a bit too assumptive
it may seem like it's possible but it's
speculative in the absence of evidence
the solution that makes the least amount
of assumptions tends to be correct Ergo
it's likely just a left Winger we know
their MO has been violence and Terror we
know they've used fire bombs we they you
have the song the famous song baby I'm
an anarchist where they say it's time to
throw bricks through Starbucks when it
came time to throw breakthrough through
a Starbucks window you left me all alone
referring to liberals we know that their
their MO has always been violence and
political Terror to get what they want
Target was the only major corporation to
pull back
on Pride
Bud Light doubled down Cole said nothing
North Face had nothing Nike said nothing
Target pulls the products back instantly
gets slammed with threats from someone
claiming to be from the left I think The
Simple Solution here is the correct one
the left is pissed that this company
backed down and so they're resorting to
their typical tactic unfortunately what
we learned from 2020 is that Target is
actually willing to risk or even sustain
real damage to their locations in order
to not say things that they think will
upset the market now unfortunately if
one of these lunatics actually does set
a bomb off or commit some other
terroristic act of violence people could
get hurt people could die however that's
not on target that's on whatever lunatic
does this I do want to point out
the title of the Washington Post article
Target stores see more bomb threats over
Pride Merchants wrong that's wrong it's
over them removing Pride merchandise but
you see how they're lying yeah yeah over
Pride merchandise just such a
manipulative uh that is an outright lie
they did not see bomb threats over Pride
merchandise they didn't they they saw it
exactly they saw a bomb they did not get
bomb threats for the pride merchandise
they got bomb threats for removing them
exact opposite yeah it should say over
lack of Pride merchandise
and get this the the writer of this
article Waits until around the the
second third uh until around 60 70
through the story before mentioning that
it was actually lgbtq people who who
were claiming to have done it this is
how the media lies it is a lie that
headline is factually false and how many
people are going to see that headline
and share it and say this is why we're
not safe in this country the right wing
is coming after us we know that they do
this all the time though they do this
with absolutely everything they make up
these fake things things that happen and
then they say oh this community they're
the most at risk from right-wing
extremism if it was if this really
happened and this was a republican like
or a right-wing person you would a
hundred thousand percent you would know
that the person's name they would be
arrested tomorrow we don't still don't
know who the Gen six bombers are right
but you would know who called in that
bomb threat if it was a right-wing
person that was doing that to Target you
would 100 know every time it will not
have the word terrorism in the title and
not only that every other brand on the
planet would be saying we stand in
solidarity with Target or there would be
some kind of Nationwide movement to
acknowledge this and have an open
dialogue which is another way of saying
a lecture from the LGBT community about
how special and good they are and how
bad and nasty we are for not accepting
their lifestyle choices
yep well it looks legit to me that the
actual threat was from who they say they
were I don't know could be a false flag
if someone's smart smart enough and
intelligence and isn't always an
indication of Good and Evil like an evil
person can be intelligent and some evil
intelligent person wanted to
create a false flag and make it look
like the LGBT community was striking out
because their materials were removed
well nice job you succeeded I mean it
really feels like angered people lash
out that's what they do I mean I don't
know what else to I just channeled a
little Jordan Peterson it's like man if
that's what you're doing you're better
for you you accomplished it you're doing
that then cut it out man it's not good
if it is not right do not do it if it is
not true do not say it amen
but this is where we're at but is that
true it's it's it's true enough and uh
it's faster pressure but look the the
the article from the new Republic this
was about Starbucks backtracking
if we start seeing Starbucks get similar
treatment we'll know exactly what's
going on far left extremists this is
their uh this is their MO I think this
is what they do I think that the fervor
is petered out on this now this pride
month it lasted a couple weeks people
know they don't need to push it so hard
like the real people that care about the
health and safety of people in different
marginalized communities don't want to
put their marginalized Community out
front and center because it just it gets
Stones thrown you don't want that
um so I think that any kind of it's the
activists that have been trying to
create some sort of political movement
that are getting their metaphorical
behinds whooped and getting kicked out
of uh the White House banned from the
White House like you don't need to
it's one thing to be accepted it's
another thing to try and change society
to to fit your world view that's not
where we're I feel like you're giving
people a lot of credit because most of
the people that I know with the
exception of you they don't just want to
be accepted and tolerated they want to
be celebrated they want to have a leg up
over the general population they want
more benefits they want they feel like
they've they've been entitled to it like
I heard somebody say on like my Twitter
the other day like this Flag represents
uh all the people who died to sacrifice
so that we could fly I'm like who died
like who was out there dyingly we would
have known we would have known their
name just like George Floyd right we
would have known every detail about them
that they actually died for the LGBT
flag stop right but but the masses they
are sick and indoctrinated and they
believe this stuff this isn't just
activists this is like crazy people
talking to each other with a
reinforcement mechanism going over and
over and over again I used to think that
it was like puppets it's not it's people
like saying oh I want it easy too or I
want some benefit of being some victim
and they they live in some Echo chamber
that keeps growing because there's
obviously benefits about being a victim
and so that's what's happening like it's
not it's not like these activists
pulling strengths they're just
capitalizing off of The psychosis of the
masses but I think the it's it's it's
about the the critical mass in this
country
most people didn't care and refuse to
engage so what happens anybody who wants
to run amok run up runs amok yep these
big corporations yes ESG plays a role
and I've been saying this for a while
it's not just that it's that they think
it makes sense it makes money for them
so let's consider this for Starbucks how
does it come to the point where they're
like take this stuff down simple there
was probably a marketing meeting where
they were like what's going on with this
Bud Light thing this is kind of worrying
and they said yeah there's a lot of
people who are angry over the pride
stuff and so they're boycotting Bud
Light sales are down 30 percent Target
sales are down targets market cap and
anheuser's market cap are going down
these other companies are seeing it too
and then Starbucks some some executive
goes okay well are we doing this they
said yes we do have a pride month
display and go okay why they're like
well I mean it was a the popular thing
to do I mean everybody did it we're just
participating and they and he probably
said okay how much money do we stand to
make by marketing to this group of
people and they were like well to be
honest the average person is going to
shop at Starbucks now matter what if we
if we do or don't celebrate this and
they went okay well how much money do we
lose if we put these flags up well Bud
Light took a 30 hit take them down
there's no benefit anymore when no one
cared there was no risk and they said eh
maybe we'll bump our sales by four
percent now that the risk is 30 plus
percent they're saying there's no reward
but they also in they also open
themselves up to Legal liability too you
have a fiduciary responsibility to your
shareholders and if you're doing things
that you know will purposely drive down
your stock you're liable right yeah so
it's their job to make money for their
shareholders if they see this stuff
going on with Bud Light and Target they
have a responsibility to stop it because
if not they're not protecting their
shareholders well and I think one thing
a lot of these organizations a lot of
these companies are going to start to
realize if they haven't already it's
that the people who they might offend in
terms of their customer base the people
who they might drive away
are people who are already shopping
there in violation of their principles
right so if you're somebody who's uh on
the far left to the point where you buy
into this gender ideology there's a
pretty strong overlap between you and
people who say things like there's no
ethical consumption under capitalism or
I hate big corporations and I think that
the means of production need to be
equitably distributed across everyone
who works within a particular sector
right so my point is people who are on
the far left who are patronizing
Corporate America are already purchasing
in violation of their principles so if
they get offended by you not celebrating
pride month the chances that they're
going to
suddenly decide to inconvenience
themselves in the name of their
principles is very low because they've
never done it before there's there's a
really strong overlap for some reason
between socialists
Communists and support for massive
multinational capitalist corporations
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time